just like to welcome everyone to the
assets and infrastructure committee
meeting for the 28th of
November and um I'd just like to welcome
uh the public
too um I'd like to um move um ask for
any any apologies I don't think there's
any no
apologies we'll move on
to thanks accept that Joe all those in
favor please say
I against it's
carried we move on to our reports
straight into it um first of all we've
got the Miri Center project report from
signal um was
Jim Jim's here no
comments um any comments from the
floor
everyone's happy about that one um would
someone move that the report be received
thanks M councelor Fraser second
councelor mcf Paul
mcf all those in favor please say
I against it's carried
the next one to cover is the
um project
register uh we had some comment or also
like to um welcome David David prentist
you're on the board are
you I Amar me yep we can hear you that's
good project register
would Jason will comment on this
one um thank you uh Mr chairman uh just
in terms of this report so we' sort of
Taken notice I guess of uh some of the
comments from the last uh committee um
taken a bit more of a cautious approach
to
um uh our particularly forward-looking
uh work program around some of the uh
the projects that we have uh on this
list and so you'll see a few more uh
oranges and some Reds and that's sort of
reflecting I guess what um you know
early on in the project uh um
particularly with those reads around the
risks in in the worst case scenario out
um outcomes so potentially just
providing a bit more of a um a visual as
to where the projects are at this point
and still I guess the ability for them
to uh to change and uh and the risk of
um them being achieved change over time
so yeah happy to have any uh questions
or comments on the
register
yes
David made that comment at the last
meeting so thank you very much um for
taking that on board but the interesting
thing is the pendulum seems to
fli mons I see a sea of green I feel
good I go to bed I SN I 10s
I think we can't necessarily see the of
the trees here so two of these projects
are actually completed and two others
are more or less completed and of the
remaines there's a large number of and
there so I at that and I'm
worried okay um through uh through the
chair I I guess what what we're just
highlighting here really is um with
these projects in particular i' sort of
focus on um the gore um Wastewater
consent renewal and the matota river
crossing project um as uh committee
members are well aware these projects do
contain a significant um element of risk
um they are they are projects that have
a number of contributing factors to them
um and um in either case particularly I
guess where we've seen um those red dots
is that if uh and again I don't want to
sort of go too much into it because we
will discuss the reports at the end but
if we aren't able to achieve a couple of
things in those prog the ability to um
monit I mean to achieve those um
projects can change but again I'll just
bring you back to the status ke um and
so orange again is around some concerns
but they're manageable so it's not a
we're out of control um it's still um we
feel that they're on track but there's
you know we've just got to watch them uh
pretty closely um and then there's um
readed where it's been closely monitored
or requires a council decision and so
those two reads again are around um the
drilling project under the river which
we know um carries risk in terms of how
we can uh we can do a lot of
Investigation into that but there are no
guarantees and then for the um
Wastewater consent renewal um that is
just we're very early on in that project
in that process um and so there's a
number of bits and pieces that have to
fall into place in order for us to
achieve um the right outcome there and I
guess we also included into that um that
red dot for the consent renewal was is
funding so that's is a a a big project
with a a significant Capital cost that
um as you're seeing now around the
country um there's certain challenges
for the ability of um of councils to
actually achieve these scale uh capital
projects so that's where um we've we've
moved to so hopefully it's not a uh a
doom and gloom or you can't sleep at
night David but hopefully um we're
providing just a little bit more of an
overview in terms of the potential risks
associated with these projects I agree
thank you thank you just just another
comment would be on the um the uh uh
consenting process would be the
availability of land too or not yes
yeah
an uh thanks Mr
chair um can you tell me what goes well
what's the criteria getting
the the works on the project register
because I'm a little bit concerned that
we haven't got HB res up Res up there
it's part of the
upgrade and to get
compliance the reservoir has to be up
and running and it has to be up and
running by 2025 so why is it not on the
register Jason you uh through the chair
so the pump stations on the terms that
construction the reservoir I think is
actually scheduled for year two of the
um
this next ltp so um we have we haven't
started the I guess the design and
detailed work for that so that project
is at this stage not uh not on there it
certainly will be and I guess it's a bit
of this overlap that um David pointed
out is we're coming to the end of a
cycle of uh completion of a significant
number of key projects and now um once
we remove um these ones that
completed and almost complete then we
will start to I guess project those um
key projects moving forward but also
acknowledging that through an ltp
process is going to be some uh feedback
on those projects and how they uh where
they should fit potentially in our in
our planning so through the ltp process
so um there's just a bit of work to
still go before we bring them onto this
project
register just just a comment um
do we actually need hillbury
have uh Reservoir in place to get the
drinking water standard complete was it
just mainly the river crossing and
getting the water across from E Score
first uh would you comment on that Jason
things yes I understand that is the case
however there are significant risks
associated with the current Reservoir at
hbv and we want to uh get those updated
but I think Aon might have a
comment thank
you um to complete the reservoir upgrade
we need to get the water across from
East first so we can't actually do the
res upgrade until that W is over
from of a two-part project so once we
can get the um
Gore uh pipeline under the river then
we'll be able to
Council Phillips thanks Mr chair so my
concern is that we have to December
2025 to be
compliant so therefore the reservoir has
to be up and running for us to be
compliant with the protoo consent so if
we don't have the reservoir and the
money set aside and virtually building
we won't get
consent in December 2025 we'll be
um out of a cons sending is that is that
correct
have2 um for for getting that compliance
signed off so that should be
um done because we'll be able to
hopefully have the pl line across and
then we'll have the plan for the fing
for that has to get approval
from just going back to my comment
though you'll have UV treated water
across if you get that pipeline across
if you plug it into the old Reservoir
it's still going to be compliant isn't
it or am I
wrong Tri order from e but yes we will
still be compant once that
thank you any further comments
nille so we don't actually need my my
way I see it is we don't actually need
the reservoir change as long as we get
the water from the membrane plant across
we will be
compliant or am I thinking
wrong no Mr chair you and I are thinking
in the same line because I I believe the
way I read it is that sure we be
compliant if we get the water across the
under under the river but if the reservo
is not up to scratch we won't get
compliance any comment from Jason or
Aon um again I
think I I I'll have to check that but I
think I think aon's um approach there is
right in the fact that if we have that
that plan in place um we will
be um therefore compliant with the
um the request for uh request by tomata
uh and if um we'll have that in place uh
will then be meeting their expectations
in terms of the uh protoo compliance but
I'll I'll go away and double check that
and uh and bring that back to you um
councelor Phillips thank thank you Jason
any any further comments uh Steve Steve
wants to comment I think when he gets
plugged in can someone pass my mic
yeah thanks uh Mr chairman um I think
Jason almost stole my thunder but what I
suggest we do rather than try and second
guess what toi might be uh contemplating
in terms of a clearance that we just go
back and report back to the count the
committee about the reservoir project
and its um importance or otherwise in
associated with drinking water
compliance as distinct from addressing
health and safety and water capacity
issues uh in the
gship councilor Phils can I also add
that we have a time frame on that two
things time frame time
frame a time frame has in said is
because we've got to be compliant by
2025 and I just want to make sure that
if we just need to have our compliance
and everything here financially that's
fine by me right but if we have to have
a complete rebuild by the reservoir then
we're going to be struggl if you know
what I mean yes sure thanks I think what
I've read is we have to have a plan and
um in place by 2025 and it's got to be
pretty
concrete we need to confirm
that well concrete means that we've
we've set in since 201 21 thinking about
building a reservoir and and it's not up
there
yet we will get a report back for that I
think um any other
comments on the re um B sorry it's
probably um think Mr chair outlined in
the um ltp but what's the reason behind
the chicken and egg situation with the
reservoir how do you how come you can't
do the res
now so this might be my lack of three
knowledge um we we to get a compliant
Reservoir we need the compliant water to
come across from East and we can't take
the current Reservoir
offline um and service the town um
without having a once the flight line
comes over from E we can pass so that
there is no res while the new one is
being built so that's the reason for
having to get that pipeline across
first thank you Aon that makes a whole
lot of
sense thank
you any other comments on the project
register someone like to move that the
report be received we can probably
follow some of the things up in detail
on each project think thank you steart
steart can you move that thank you
second Joe Stringer seconded that all
those in favor please say I against it's
carried we go on to
the Elizabeth Street U Water Services
upgrade and um any comment from
Jason no just happy to take the report
as read and if there's any questions we
between ter and myself for respond
us lots of hands um councilor M
mcell uh just a quick comment that the
street looks good I had a drive up today
the road burns look look good and most
of the Tas ceiling's been done into the
driveways so it's starting to look very
very tidy again thank you Council pH
phaser yeah just one comment on and I
hopefully I did my maths right the sto
three properties that have not approved
or there's no movement in connection is
that correct and help far along with
that yeah through you Mr chair um
there's been some significant um updates
on the private property Stu since this
report was written and so your question
was in related to are three still just
three properties to be
connected oh there was three that were
unaccounted for in
the we I see
that oh I think I might have gone the
wrong way I think you may be talking
about the original 62 yes yeah um what's
happened is that as we've been going
through so that original number was put
in um based off a non-site assessment if
you will as we've been continuing we've
been assessing the sites and some of
those properties that were included in
that 62 do not require separation
because it already been
done uh just just to add to that um I
think the number in the report says 29
it's actually up to 35 properties
completed now
so that's um it's still um six seven
seven properties to complete plus seven
properties to do design for is
it yep there's a number of um we still
haven't looked at some of them so
although the designs are in place we
haven't initiated the building consent
process basically because the um the
contractors have been inundated with
work I just didn't want to upload them
but
the original intention was to get them
all finished before Christmas but we're
going to be into March I think
now thank
you any further
questions councilor frer um I was
reading in that too the they're talking
about infiltration rate in the last
downpour we have was not up to
expectations can you expand on that a
little bit please yeah um so through you
Mr chair um the design for the
infiltration rate had requested um 50 mm
an hour of infiltration and when the
testing was done we got significantly
less than that despite the fact that the
um the the B is now operational and and
it's working Us in terms of the design
uh we're not getting the um infiltration
rates that was designed for so we've
asked the contractor to go back and do
some assessments on the soils and the
types the materials that they put in
there so we're waiting for that report
to come back from for Hogan um yeah
so any want to
comment
no no further comments
uh no further comments on Elizabeth
Street or um someone recommend that the
report be
received Council mcell and councilor
Richard mcf seconded it all the those in
favor please say I against it's
carried um councilor Phillips will
second in the mean time we'll keep
moving
on technical
point he's not so uh Council Phillip
seconded with those all those in favor
please say I against it's carried thank
you for picking that
up the escore
um water treatment plant upgrade is
there any comments on that from is that
from an
Aaron oh Jason's going to do this yes
thank
you again happy to take the report as
read and any questions um we'll note um
that there's still the ongoing noise
issue that we're um remedying um and
there's hope to have that final piece of
that work in place um next month and get
that retested um so that's uh
effectively what's the final part of
that
um that project um and we're hoping to
have that completed um as soon as
possible um question from
Robert
try another
one just uh as a matter of as a matter
of Interest the the noise is it is it
like a low frequency hum or is it um an
out there higher pitch noise CU some of
those low frequency noises can be hell
of a things to get rid
of Jason would you like to go
there possibly won't comment on the type
of noise because don't have to listen to
it but uh regardless of what type of
noise it is the the testing by um that
we got undertaken by Marshall day um it
exceeded um the district plan
requirements um and as part of the
design contract um it was there FS with
Marshals to remedy that uh that part of
the process and that's what we've been
working with them over the past few
months to to get sorted and so uh um
we'll go through this process and
hopefully see um that new testing show
that it complies um otherwise we'll be
looking Marshalls for further upgrades
to make sure it does thank you for that
it's just that comment that you know
different frequency sounds low frequency
sounds carry a long way like low down
hums and they're hell of a things to get
rid of but uh it's just a comment thank
you thank you no no further
questions that project's pretty much
come to an end and it's it's would be
good to see it finished um been thank
you Mr chair apologies for my Swift exit
there didn't mean to disturb the meeting
we still on the El Elizabeth Street item
no we jumped onto the score but am I
able to C back sorry Mr cheer um just on
the fences um after copying in the neck
from a number of members of the public
during the floods um is there a plan for
that report to come to
council Jason was going to come to me
about that I'll get him to come in uh
yes we have received uh a number as well
a number of
um issues around that um and again we
wanted to see first of all that um
before any fencing out taken that the
the um the retention Basin is operating
as it is because it's we don't want to
fence it and then have to go back in and
do work and so there's some reports on
that infiltration rate um as as teor
outlined um and obviously we've had a
couple of um significant rainfall events
which have showed what the the Basin
does and it is still um draining away
pretty quickly but it's uh has raised
some concerns with residents so we will
be bringing a a report back to council
around um around fencing that um and
also the one potentially looking at the
one at metto Ridge as well which is
another Basin although a bit different
to the um the scenario we have at
Elizabeth Street certainly on the radar
thank
you it to
you yes we we moved that I
think okay we have a mve for to rep
receive the report for eore water plant
councelor Fraser and a second coun P MF
all those in favor please say
I
against
carried uh we'll move on to the wam
Street Wastewater Mains replacement
update which is pretty much complete um
any reports from
staff um thank you Mr cheer
um again uh this is pretty much complete
um we were pretty close last time um
again this just want to highlight the
this was a pretty complex project uh
from start to finish Crossing through a
number of different land owners the
railway State Highway um there was a lot
of opportunity to things to go quite
poorly here and they haven't and so I
just want to acknowledge um the
contractors involved in this project um
and the staff whove worked
collaboratively um alongside some of
those stakeholders to get this um
through on time and under budget so
that's um um I think a rewarding project
for the for the team and um deserve um
the acknowledgement for doing that um
and and trying to keep that to a disrupt
disruption to a
Minima happy to take any
questions I'd just like to comment also
that it's good to see U project
completed on time and in
budget and uh well well done any
comments from any other
counselors Council Phillips thank you Mr
Chief barer record congratul ulations
Jason well
done no more
comments um just going to jump in there
with a well done as well to get uh
almost 25% under budget is is pretty
impressive so I'm very well done to the
to yourself on the
team would someone like to move that
this report be
received councelor Jo strer seconded by
Council M mcell all those in favor
please say I Against
it's
carried the partial D sludging of the
gore oxidation ponds project update
um going to hand that over to
Jason um again another one that's uh
been completed uh pretty much this year
um and another one we we had a a good
relationship with uh contractors
involved to get that um
that one completed with a little bit of
the contingency left over so um yeah
happy to take any questions really
around that
oneone very quot it's a well another
comment it is another project well done
and completed and um I dare say it'll be
ongoing in the future of what we have to
do down
there um Mr Perry yeah thanks Mr
chairman I just like to um really just
point out that both those projects both
the wgan street um Wastewater main trunk
main replacement and this D sludge
really does significantly reduce the
risk that was posed to the council only
as recently as a year or two ago I
recall the 2020 flood when that Wigan
Street pipeline was exposed and we
thought gee there the r go goes that
whole whole trunk Main and the D
sludging Co we've had capacity issues
there and this is the first time it's
been Des sludged since the ponds were
put in place back in the mid '70s so
it's quite both of them are quite
Milestone projects but they do lower the
council's risk uh to failure which I
think this should be recorded as being
quite
comforting thank
you Council
McKenzie just a refresh of my memory
please Jason what happens to the bags
now and what's the timeline on
them
this may be a question uh better suited
for Matt or Terry but um uh basically
those they my understanding is they will
sit there now and they um they basically
dry out and it's over a period of time
and then once the fully um dewatered
those bags then the the residual residue
and waste is is taken then off site for
disposal so it's it's it's a non-toxic
type of dried out waste that can be
buried un approved facility correct
thank
you Council
Phillips thank you Mr chair I don't want
to be a Slayer of good news but what
happens to the contingency because we
took money from
Elsewhere for it to complete this
project
Jason um being a capital project and
that the um effectively um debt funded
it's uh I can't remember the figure is
$100,000 of debt that we don't have to
draw down and and then pay back so
that's where the the saving is
1055 yes thank
you uh thank you Mr chair I was actually
going to make that point but for all of
them there's quite a significant
contingency um available across um all
the projects racking up to almost a
million dollars which is pretty
impressive in terms of um debt we don't
have to pull down um I guess what I was
wondering is whether the the um
demolition of the water tower then comes
back onto the list to be considered
again now that we have a bit more
contingency or or kind of where that
sits considering we've pulled money away
from that
project probably Jason go on this one
yeah exactly um look that's um really
good question in terms of um I guess and
and that'll be one of the critical
things I guess in front of Council in
terms of the long-term plan for three
Waters is what projects we prioritize
we've already talked about uh the Mata
River Crossing project the H Revenue um
Reservoir and we've also got the tower
there um but we still have that even
though we've um haven't spent everything
in those projects um it means we we
we're still well aware that we've got a
limited borrowing capacity and so we've
got to still make some decisions through
that long-term plan process about what
we can um achieve in the in the short
term in particular so that'll be the
challenge for you
guys no more comments on the
dislodging um would someone like to move
that that report we
received Council mcell um seconded by
the
mayor as we um all those in favor please
say I against
carried the gore and materi wi water
consent r project update this is just in
its infancy just the start of it um
Jason thank you Mr chair um so as
detailed in Met's report
um the uh Consultants now looking into
the detailed investigations after
confirming a short list of options um
that's being developed we've uh also had
uh some on-site investigations done uh
looking at the suitability of some sites
uh for our ongoing Wastewater consent um
renewal needs and the key part of that
process now is uh completing that design
um the detailed
investigation um early next year and
looking at a a preferred option um for
that so we can Lodge a consent with um
environment South and so we're going to
be tight pushing through to April to get
that um in place but um we continue um
keeping es updated um and we um as um as
cheia stated um there's also some uh
chicken and egg around uh potential um
land options and when we may have to go
through a um discussion negotiation
around land purchase but um that's a
part of that process working forward
happy to take any questions or comments
does does this project line itself up
for this um fund that the government are
meeting through the cheer I hope so um
these uh these Wastewater upgrades are
significant costs and we're not the only
ones that are feeling them um even now
you look at our neighbors southern
district they've got numerous uh
Wastewater consents um it'll be a
challenge too for inago City and
councils across the country and I guess
is what one of the the drivers for water
reforms whe whatever way that looks so
um we're certainly going to need some
funding assistance and any funding
available from central government we
certainly be uh putting a hand up and
again one of being one again first cab
off the rank in terms of um getting our
consent in it puts us well placed to
sort of hopefully access fund sooner
rather than later
thank
you councilor
Phillips thank you Mr chair like I just
like to thank the staff on the continued
um ha pulling I presume on on on this
issue and and and it just goes to show
that uh you know the money that
that central government have put upon
local governments to be wasted and poor
rate poers are yet funding the bill and
um you know like and I'm pretty sure
that if every rate power has seen this
report
about how much money the sips has been
so far just on consing on on two pawns
plus one ker you know I
just it gives me uh it gives me evidence
when I'm I'm a um confronted by a ray
about you know how much money we're
spending and this is one of the reasons
and and I just hope that central
government get on board and open their
eyes to what's happening out
here thank you Council frer yeah thanks
Mr chair and I totally agree with what
nille said what I've got down here we're
have a budget within a year what's it
going to be like forther down the track
and it just seems like an endless money
put to appease central
government any other
comments we look forward to um
progressing this
project sorry the
mayor thank you here I'm just struggling
to formulate my question but what what
year would this need to be enacted this
this process when we need to is it 2027
this need to be completed by this this
project or is it dependent on the
consent or
it'ses the comment myself it's the
consent we're looking forward to get and
then the process of actually doing the
work will be over could be over 20
years
even it could be longer than that time
the whole Project's
finished
Jason yeah I think that'll that'll come
out through the the consent process so
as part of um once we actually get the
consent into environment South and then
they'll probably put a we'll hopefully
be able to work with them to negotiate a
term which will then u mean we need to
have um this in place by exate could be
specul in terms of what that looks like
but again it's understanding that um we
do have operating
um uh existing operations there and it's
just a matter of what's the time frame
to to get that implementation of these
consents at a significant
cost thank you for that I guess where my
question was leading as um currently
we're we're taking out three Waters as
of
2025 and our long-term plan if we're
suddenly told to put it back in what
does that look like in terms of the
allocation towards that um throughout
our long-term plan um or would we
largely leave it out until we know more
what does that kind of look like in the
meantime it
would Mr Perry like to comment on that
one I just only caught the that into
your question your worship so was that
about what it looks like in that
long-term plan this particular project
financially um yeah
it's it's very good question because
some of the um the work will be
determined by the consent that's issued
and the the Milestone
based um timetable that's likely to be
involved in that consent uh so I think
what we off the top of my head I think
there will be possibly um obviously the
uh the cost of securing consent
um and we may allocate some money for
example lights of some land purchase uh
towards the 10year timeline of the of
the consent uh but the actual physical
Works May well be part of our
infrastructure strategy but may not be
in the 10year timeline of the ltp off
the top of my head that's probably what
I think might we land on um it's fair to
say this is the type of project that
given our debt covenants with um the Loc
government funding agency we're going to
need external assistance and we're going
to need a lot of it um because the the
numbers associated with this uh project
are pretty daunting um but again as
others have mentioned we're not the only
Council in this in this particular uh
predicament we're probably one of the
few that are entering a consent process
though uh a number of looking at what it
needs to be done we're actually in the
slipstream of applying for consent uh
and we are we we we will get in the end
of it uh um hopefully a consent but a a
commitment to do certain things over a
certain period of time uh and quite uh I
think quite likely that will be
involving probably getting their
discharge out of the river because to e
that's that's the a bottom line
imperative thank you any further
questions it's a big picture
yeah no no thank you thank you for that
I guess it's a big what if exercise and
with the uncertainty around three Waters
of I guess my fear is if we have to put
three Waters back in all of a sudden and
trying to fit in a project that we
simply can't afford it's it's going to
make things very messy but um gu it's
largely out of our hands
unfortunately whether this is in the
three Waters or outside the three Waters
the public will still have to
pay Mr Perry Just further I think as
worships correct and look uh it just
highlights the fact that um three Waters
uh what the council's new Zeal are fac
with is the the double whammy of Aging
infrastructure infrastructure that was
put in place to to a large degree with
the benefit of central government
systems over the decades until the 80s
and then on top of that Rising
environmental standards you put those
two together and you've got a perfect
Financial storm which uh for councils is
just a step too far and some external
funding needs to come from the center
because all the clever maneuverings
around
um um splitting your balance sheet and
put and creating new entities the bill
still gets hit home to the same consumer
um and I think for New Zealand
Incorporated we need an external funding
source outside local rate payers to
deliver this these necessary
upgrades thank you very very timely
comment there needs it probably needs
more pressure on central government but
I there say this every Council in New
Zeal will be putting that pressure
on any further comments um would someone
like to move that this report be
received councelor Stringer and
councelor Fraser second it all those in
favor please
say
against it's
carried
the Mata River Crossing project update
um something that's actually in the
process and uh Jason would report on
this
one uh thank you Mr chair
um so in terms of this project um the
scope really of this financial year is
around the um design and investigations
for this with the um delivery of this
project project um scheduled for year
one of the ltp so the 2425 year um
Headley and Brunton uh the sort of
specialists in this um uh industry have
uh responded with a um expression of
interest and we're working through um
options with them and Becca who have um
done the preliminary design um as and
and those two uh working through
investigation currently um recently met
um with Headley and Brunton who um again
their significant experience um in
particularly locally as well um provided
some different pipe options which um
we're considering along with making sure
we allow for additional capacity for
future growth so um this will just this
is a as stated earlier
um complex project um but one that is
critical um uh to our infrastructure and
ensuring that um all the residents of
the gore Township are um having um Pro
our uh compliant drinking water and
that's something we want to um get
through and completed as soon as
possible so we're working um hard to
make sure we get that across the
line happy to take any comments or
questions May ban B
thank you chair um bit of a roller
coaster reading the design and
consenting when I saw the um old clean
field site my heart sank and thought
that we were going to run into problems
but I'm glad to read at the end there um
that no significant uh concerns were
raised um just I guess actually want to
say a huge um thank you and
congratulations to uh staff primarily
but also to elected members of making a
decision um on this project it means
that we uh actually have a chance of
getting in before this uh 2025 deadline
um which we wouldn't have done if we
continue to muck around and decide which
way we were going to go so um really
happy that we've we've made the decision
um that we're underway in this projects
going um obviously touching wood um that
this project continues to go well um I
know it's highly Technical and there's a
long road to go um but I'm I'm glad
we've at least got a shot to to meet
those those regulations so I'm really
well done everyone
councelor M now Jason have we done any
actual drilling along the site to see
what the Rock beards like and and that
this the David appr said those dots were
keeping him awake at night this is a
project that keeps me awake at night cuz
I can just see it at consuming that
million dollars that me being talked
about having a saving very quickly if it
goes
wrong
uh through the chair uh yeah absolutely
so we those those um uh CS have been
drilled and and those investigations uh
have taken place um and so again that
can only provide you with a certain
amount of certainty um in terms of the
this type of project but um again using
uh Headley and Brunton who are familiar
with locals and that's why sort of the
recommendation around pipe sizes has
been provided to try and again eliminate
the risk of
um
uh at failing um and so there's um it's
been it's been good to work through that
but yeah look it is what it is we are
certainly trying to tick every box that
we can um and we'll certainly uh be
coming to council uh regularly on this
project um as we um particular as we
start to finalize that design and get
get ready to push the uh the go button
for it moving forward but yeah certainly
understand the uh the some of the
concerns the council
mcdonell just a comment um is it two two
tunnels or one and what size pip 250
mil yeah through a chair um it was
originally proposed that two pipes at
225 and hudley and brunton's come back
and they proposed uh up to four pipes at
a smaller diameter which will give a
extra capacity over and above the two
pipes that was initially asked for plus
it's uh reducing their risk so we're
waiting for that report to come back
from hard Brun thank
you any comments from
counselors yep D
it couple of comments
Reflections from
um being this project is clearly the
highest project just know you the six
categories that we've got I think one of
them are green four of
them so we should take this very
seriously
especially sure everybody in the room
knows that increases the r as well look
at the risk section at the end on page
46 I'm a little bit surprised that
there's not a clear definition of the
technical risks in the and risks are
being and imp delay should we have any
issues with the direction
drill will do the second
Point reflection away from this meeting
is there's obviously
a as we discussed Reservoir is
contingent on the successful completion
of this project so I I wonder whether
it's worthwhile and you may already
wonder actually shows the
interdependencies between the two
projects and what mighten if there is
actually a signicant delay in
the might to issues now I'm sure you all
but I I I'm not sure I fully understand
the risks in this project yet and what
the could be on Street res and as
I ability for us to get a
success it's a question for Jason but I
think all in the room realize the risk
and we do hope and pray that the four
holes under the river are suc
successful but we do need need
contingencies um through the chair yep
no great points um David I think
uh given um given how significant this
project is um I
think just a bit more information we can
we can pull together to give councilors
a bit more uh Clarity around where the
projects at what our uh I guess
our um our risks are and what I guess
you know worst case you know what what
plans b c and d might be um and so
that's we we can I think what I'm what
I'm hearing from the committee um is um
the the level of risk which we're all
aware of and we can certainly provide a
bit more detail into this report in
particular given its significance and
importance to cor District
thank
you is there any comments from
councilors councelor
Phillips thank you Mr chair well I'd be
interested to see what your
contingencies are
because I never voted for this I voted
for a bridge but at the end of the day
we' got to take a risk somewhere along
the line and and I I feel that's um part
of the contingency if if it's too great
is that we think about redesigning and
rebuilding the hillbury air Reservoir it
don't you won't need a big one you only
need a little one as part of the
contingency councelor
mfow through the chair I I think this
whole project one of the big things is
we got to keep the public informed on
what we're doing because there's been a
lot of discussion about this before now
and the significant risk we have and the
possibilities in the future is if we can
somehow I don't know front put this um
in a positive way is what we need to do
I believe anyway it's just my
thought CC
Fraser yes um I'm I'm a bit like councel
Phillips you know I prefer a pipe to be
above the ground than under it and like
Council Phillips I wondered why you
couldn't upgrade the side of the river
as a contingency because drilling
underground the risk and everybody's
mentioned that the cost could be
astronomical the ongoing cost or the
halfway cost or whatever under this
build and design type system that
they're
suggesting councel
Phillips yeah we I've also got now a
problem when they changed the
consistency in the aspect of the design
is that we were thinking about two pipes
and two two shots and now we're looking
at four shots which is four times the
risk um even though you think you're
going to get a little bit more capacity
yeah it's got my concern thanks Aaron is
it Phillips um the reason they're
looking at four shots is it's less risky
than doing the two shots um because they
can do it a lot
quicker um and on the um why we didn't
upgrade the treatment plant on the north
at North at h
um the compliance
costs um ongoing compliance costs and
build costs of a new treatment plant to
make the drinking water standards would
far exceed what we are currently looking
at for this project and then we only
have one ongoing plant that we have to
maintain um throughout the
core it's interesting um when I was
doing drainage I do drainage at home for
the farm and we had a me grage man
teaching us how to do it and he said oh
a half inch pipe is far stronger than a
2in pipe and if example wasse if you lay
it on the ground and you run over with a
car the half inch pipe would probably
survive but the 2in pipe would get
squashed Mr Perry yeah Mr chairman I
think uh it's really relevant
conversation but I think just to remind
all speakers that uh this project and
its alternatives are all laced with risk
there is no kind of cotton W safe route
to get to where we want to uh we we've
always known that direct Drilling in the
river is fra with risk and uncertain
cost but so was a bridge with consenting
issues and construction cost Rises um I
I think really that the council's had a
a very comprehensive debate about the
options it's it's um uh headed towards
direct drilling under the river but as
the project matures and if other um
things come to the for that weren't
contemplated when the council decision
was made it may behove uh officers to
come back to the council fresh but I
don't think we're there yet but
obviously if the costs do balloon out um
as the design uh and build approach um
or construct approach uh materializes
then we just need to keep in tune with
the original rationale behind making the
decision and whether that's still
applicable or if there's been any
changes since that time that would
warrant a review of that particular
decision thank
you um mean being B I guess it does
raise a good point then of if we're now
doing four smaller sh shots does that
then double the price or is that still
an
unknown cuz I know it lowers the RIS but
doesn't increase the price I'm see Aaron
saying no Aaron would like to
[Music]
comment um you Mr my understanding is
it's it's not going to increase the cost
um it's going to make it more certain
that they can do it within the costs by
doing the four shots but may
elate yeah through you uh Mr chair I'll
concur with ain's statement and that
that is how the um Project's being put
across to us from hardle Brunton is that
they're looking to minimize the risk for
the project and if the risks are uh both
financial and constructibility I think
we're going to reduce them by4 PES and
the hav indicated that the costs are
going to be
higher thank
you C
FS um just a question then so what's the
capacity increase then by putting in the
four shots compared to the two what's
the percentage
difference it back to
the Jason will comment yeah look I I
think we're probably bit early in the
conversation for that and this has just
been a um an option provided at this
stage by Headley and Brunton as part of
the investigation works and so um we're
working actually you know again moving
from two pipes to um four pipes
decreases the risk but there's also
changes to pressure and things like that
so there's a lot of that's part of this
investigation and we're trying to you
know again understand those now so this
is why we're um taking this sort of
approach checking all options um and
certainly then from there we're a best
place to make a decision about what the
best option is to to get the the job
done but certainly just options at this
stage it's not certainly going one way
or the
other
Paul thank you chair just so Jason if
they do the first drill and find it's
easy going are they not going to are
they just going to stick with two then
you know is that the possible scenario
no
they've decided before is what they want
to do and just go with
it com com so yeah just
um again what what the contractor is um
is looking at is just based on
experience a smaller pipe diameter has
certain you know less risk and so again
there's a lot of work to go through um
and then what what the in terms of this
process we'll get to the end of that
investigation finalize what the the the
designers and then what the cost is and
then we'll come back to council and just
confirm before we then enter into that
final contract um in terms of um the
construction about where we're heading
and so again it's not a um this is an
important part but certainly we'll
keeping Council informed of that and
then therefore through that process
we'll have a bit more certainty to say
to our community as well but through
this investigation this is what we found
this is what we believe is the best
option this is what we're to go
for thank you councelor st three Mr
cheer um I was just going to say having
had some experience on horizontal
thrusting machines and um directional
drilling um as you go larger in your um
B size the heads that you use for doing
your thrusting get exponentially higher
and cost like up to half a million
dollars so if you shear your string off
halfway through the thrust you can lose
half a million dollars just like that
and sometimes it's not recoverable so
having those smaller heads which can get
down to $3 $40,000 on the smaller one
it's likely to lose it and you've still
got high tension and your string behind
it too so it comes down to those cost
benefits and you can get away with a
smaller rig as well you don't need to
have a um traffic management plan to to
shift the big heav machine we can use a
smaller five 5 to 10 T
machine thank
you no further discussion on this
project someone like to move that the
report be received and the risk received
Council M
now is
second um being B May second it all
those in favor please say I against it's
carried
um we're over to the compliance
compliance requirements for
produ barriers and drunking Water
Supplies M Terry Terry is this
one
Jason uh thank you Mr chair um I guess
with effectively covered this off um in
some of the previous conversation so uh
again really happy to sort of take
questions but as you will all be aware
this has sort of uh flared up a little
bit since um the issue arose in
Queenstown um and so uh certainly been a
bit of a push uh nationally around um
the need for compliance again and so
this is just really um going out to walk
council's assessing what
the assessing what the lack of
compliance is and what the plan is to
get these um
uh uh standards in place and so this uh
hopefully reasonably self-explanatory
there but um happy to take any questions
or
comments councilor Fraser yeah I toly
agree with you Jason because I was
reading through that later in in
paragraph 2 on page 53 and it says for
the psychic clarity funding or
affordability challenges are not bias
for failing to comply with the
legislation that is
right any other
comments um there no more comments on
that that the some recommendation is the
report be received and that the council
notes temporary R expectations for
achieving compliance with requirements
for prot barriers and drinking water
supplies at um any cost councelor Fraser
is going to move
that is second councelor strer thank you
all those in favor please say I
against hang
on can I just ask a question yep can
this report go to the audit and risk
committee because at the end of there I
believe that this is a a quite a risky
um thing that we need to make sure that
we comply with compliance Etc in the in
the Years
stated it's noted uh I think something
went you can just pass it on to Mr Perry
thank
you all those in favor please say o
against
carried
the Matera Water Treatment Plant upgrade
another project it's firstly completed
just a few more
things uh thank you Mr chair um yes so
again uh I guess a pleasing project um
really good engagement uh across the
contractors and uh a number of Staff
obviously a project staff with met and
interior but also our operations team uh
led by Aaron but also significant
contributions from Ian low and and
Daniel um down at the uh in terms of how
this will uh operate on a day to-day so
really good team effort um and sort of
happy to get this uh this upgrade
complete um just a few miscellaneous um
tidy UPS there um but another one that
sort of stayed pretty well on time and
and with a little bit budget in there
too so um uh it's it's a pleasing
result any any
comments councilor Phillips sorry Mr
chair I seem to be speaking a bit today
but um it's just another VOC um as I
said at the community board meeting um
two meetings ago now uh just
congratulate the staff on on the on this
project um and operating getting the
material plant operational in
compliant um I've spoken to The
Operators and they're more than happy
with the way it's performing um
considering what it was like and I look
forward to uh having a visit and seeing
what the upgrades have
been thank
you we've had um visit in the old plant
and it'll be good to see the new
plant it will we hope it's clean
entirely like my last one when I left it
you used to have it polished and
any
Jason yeah just on that comment I'm not
sure whether that's gone out yet or not
but there there is something here coming
around that that uh visit so it'll be
good to get um community board and and
council is that interested up there and
um and
hopefully a public open day at some
stage too would be uh
great good achievement add cancel FS
just um once again I just note the
contingency funding I know that it's
probably wise to put it back into the
debt but we just sort of consider having
to think about um putting some a little
bit of of that money aside for more
drilling of balls for sourcing a a good
source of
water just a thought just a thought
yeah would someone move that the report
be received
then councelor Phillips is there second
Council back now all those in favor
please say
I against it's
carried hillbury a um Pump Station
project
um
J
Jason Terry can jump into here um not
much really to um add here it's due to
be completed early
2024 um unless there's anything you want
to add um he to ask questions but I
think T can jump in uh through you Mr
chair I would I haven't been involved in
this project heavily I would say
probably ain's probably got more of a a
brief on it than I would
have Aaron would you like to come
in in House of this project so um we
resing that as we can and hope to get
that completed as soon as we
can thank you uh there's a question from
David no no just waving your
hands thank
you no no further comments on the uh HB
a pump stations would someone move that
the report be
received Council Phillips secondary
councelor Mell all those in favor please
say I against it's carried move over to
um three Waters Matera Wastewater
compliance update Aaron I
think thank you Mr
um and answer
questions any questions from the
counselors or
staff
I think the only hiccups is that um when
we had plant shutdowns and change
overs no comments would someone like to
move that the report be received
councilor Fraser second Council Stringer
those in favor please say
I against it's carried
three watersa waste water compliance
update Aon
again that we've me all our consent
requirements on this one and to take any
further
questions no questions
uh someone move that this report receive
councelor Stringer has there a secondary
counc M now those in favor please say I
against carried move on to the three
wers Gore Wastewater compliance
update thank
[Music]
you having exceed on their
80th
um the 80% is a average of the last four
samples but these samples are going back
some of them are 3 years old so um it's
quite hard to get out of that but next
time the riv up we will be taking some
more samples to get
80% any
questions any questions
I even note environment South and
recommend you do
that uh Council Phillips yeah I just see
that uh During the period of time when
the material water plant was um in its
process of upgrading we we missed a
couple of consents due to the chemicals
used was that due to
the the uh what kind of chemicals were
being used do you
know
we Mr you elate more phips I'm just
looking at the waste compliance
for I might have jumped
one next one there
that might be the next one would someone
like to move that the um three wers
compliance update for cor be received or
did you want to question Council
strer yeah through you Mr cheer um just
looking at the system where um there's a
bit on
page 74 about the use of UV light and um
back
in uh August low light level conditions
do we UV treat on the way
out looks like read like we do do some
treatment there but it's not quite doing
the purpose is that
correct when the river condition River
flow is above 60 c um we don't um do any
um UV treatment um and during that um
period of time where we've had to
succeed that UV light or UV unit wasn't
operational because it's not a
requirement under the consent um and one
thing that we've decided is we will be
using that UV unit at all times to try
and keep our limits
down
thank
you no more questions um would someone
like to move that this report be
received councelor Stringer and a
seconder councelor Mell all those in
favor please say I against it's carried
we'll move on to the three Waters
Tam monthly compliance
report than you Mr um as you can see the
we have
umile compliance and compliance been
comp to Crystal compliance apart from
the help we have um and I'm happy to
take any questions thank
you councelor THS yeah that was my
question I apologize for jumping the
line a bit but um I say that the
material water plant it was
non-compliant five times
and that was due
to in your report it says about the
treatment upgrade of the CH chemical use
and the
coagulant had changed and then now you
revert it back to the old old K is that
going back to alen was
it the design was for us to be using a
under the new treatment uh we had
because it wasn't working as optimal as
it been designed to uh We've referred a
data using Pac as aul and we getting
really good results with that the rest
of the um little non-compliances or um
non compliance periods in their time
were due to the scatter upgrades going
on at the treatment PL um and exp those
to to
my thank you no for
questions just a just a question did it
put much extra cost using the PAC back
to
it you Mr chair um I just couldn't quite
get that much signals cutting out using
the polym was it
um bit more expensive or was it uh is it
a cheaper option than using the
AC you Mr chair the AC is a little bit
more expensive um than the PAC um the
PAC is a lot more tolerable to um toity
changes um whereas the Alum can be um
pretty FR fragmented and you have to be
a lot more so the PAC is a lot more um
suitable and more used throughout the
country thank
you good good move
then would someone like to move that
this report be
received Council Fraser
seconder Council M now all those in
favor please say I
against it's
carried we move over to the walkon
investment audit report technical audit
November
2022 and um maray will comment on this
one through Mr cheer um yes hopefully
the the report um is
self-explanatory um the probably the the
main thing to look at or one of the
important things to look at is the um
the uh progress on implementation on uh
the various uh recommendations and
suggestions that um wui have made in in
their um audit report uh I think from
memory all of the all of the um both uh
recommendations and suggestions uh work
in progress so we we uh are in the
process of implementing and a number of
them have been uh fully implemented um
so um if there's any question and I'd
also like to apologize for not uh
attaching the the um the technical
report uh to the report that came to
council council's
initially thank
you is there any questions from the
councilors council
Phillips just just a question by the um
the ram system have you um given thought
about giving it to the local contractor
to be able to onsite changes or do you
allow that or
not uh sorry could you repeat question I
didn't quite understand in your in your
RAM system I see it failed you know
because it hasn't been imported
sometimes right do you allow the the
contractor that you that currently
service us allow them access to the ram
system so safe arguments take they've
got a a broken post and renew it as a
new asset do you allow them to make the
changes or do they have to come back to
you to make the changes uh through you
Mr chair uh we do um uh currently uh
have our contract our routine road
maintenance contract uh which is K2 um
um uh does have that ability and they
use it uh they use a a um some Hardware
called pocket Ram um in the field uh so
they they do that uh with the other
contracts uh we're not um the the
smaller contracts were not um uh doing
that with those contracts but it's
easier for us to input that uh
information um
ourselves thank you
is there any um further questions on
this one some some councilors probably
haven't had too much time to read
it thank you Joe
St three Mr chair um can we just bring
this um report to the next roading
committee as well just to address some
of the stuff on as well
please thank you I think that would be a
good recommendation would someone like
would you like to move
that Y is there a second Council now
those in favor please say
I against
carried just Council being bail mayor
being bail sorry thank you Mr so
quick find the ones I want to
ask uh so R 2.2 um which is on page 87
um so it ensures the has an adequate
amount of drainage I know that we from
memory we up the drainage and our
request I guess the question is is that
going to be sufficient the amount that
we've asked
for and also supplementary to that when
is the time frame that we me to hear
back on what they think of our requests
and whether they're accepted or
not through through uh Mr cheer um
uh so the um the amount that we
requested
uh Pro probably um we we could always do
with more uh but we we've actually just
received today um approval of increased
funding for the current year as well um
which I um you may recall that the
council uh Council approved an increase
in the funding for last Financial year
in this financial year uh and we have
put in a cost scope adjustment request
to uh ncta for for this year to match
the increase that the uh local uh share
has has um been made um so that has been
approved by Council so we this current
year um that will extend uh our ability
to uh to do more of that work uh in this
in this current year hopefully that um
answers your query thank you sorry just
also on the the overall request that
we've had as well when will we hear back
on that yeah uh through through uh you
Mr Cher um we haven't uh had any
feedback um at the stage regarding our
our um request over the whole program
for the 24 to 27 program uh we sorry
we've had some informal uh um feedback
where the ngta have have indicated
that our um requests appears to be
reasonably prudent um compared with some
other requests but um that that's not a
a formal um approval of the program so
um that may be delayed by the change in
government um the uh there's quite a a
difference in the policy settings in the
transport area that um the the um the
new government indicated prior to the
election so that may have a bearing on
the final outcome for those for our
request but I think our is likely to be
successful or or very close to
successful over the whole
program thank you
Jason hope we didn't lowo
them no no just a couple of things on
that first um yeah it's it's actually
good that uh some of the um requested
improvements align with what we've asked
for um to walk cah on the um in terms of
our draft activity management plan for
roading um however I will um canvas that
with the fact that if we go back three
years and we look at what happened in
the last long-term plan cycle um there
were verbal uh Communications around the
fact that there was a likelihood this
was going to go over the line and then
in May 5 weeks out before Alpay adoption
um there was a bit of a slashing burn
across the board so um we won't count
our chickens uh but we'll certainly um
continue to advocate for this work and
this is where these technical audits do
come into play you know we're asking us
to spend more in certain areas we want
to do that we also need the funding
support from W kah to match that so um
yeah good that there's alignment there
but certainly uh until they approve it
in writing we'll wait and
see and probably as a governance um we
probably need to look at how you know
there's going to be increased funding
needed in the roading
budget I'm being sorry uh just one other
one I had uh which is the s5.1 on page
90 the very last one um is GDC roading
staff program to undertake night
inspections what is this actually um
looking for and and where where are
these being taken um which which route
is
this three Mr Cher uh so night
inspections are basically a safety audit
uh of the network um so we're looking at
signs and marker pigs are the generally
the um the the items that we're looking
at so we're looking to see to make sure
that um signs and Mark Peaks that should
be there are are actually there and also
um looking at the effectiveness of of
those um uh those items um whether they
they're reflective or not uh it's
something that we can't do during the
daytime because um uh they look totally
different at night something that looks
uh obvious in the daytime um um may be
invisible at night time so um we're
looking at all those sorts of um
issues thank you very much and one last
one um in the report under unseal
roads um it's got that there was a Mis
sta entry of $12
million um that was just a mistake on
our end they didn't think they had given
us $12 million and not actually wasn't
on their records by any chance just on
our end uh through you Mr chair the um
so that that uh era um my it was it it
occurred uh in my absence um but my
understanding that it was an error and
on our part we we we didn't actually uh
as far as I'm aware didn't claim it and
we didn't receive it so it was a um
an error in the in the Box um so we
don't have to give back $12 million or
if that's the
concern um yeah it it it should have
been quite obvious at the time because
12 million that's more than our um more
than our three-year program basically so
um
yeah sticks out sticks out in the graph
real
bad thank you both for that really
appreciate
[Music]
it Council
Phillips just a question for your
inspections Mar do you do it inhouse or
do you do it by
contractor Mr chair um so uh the
intention going forward is that um we do
it uh combined um uh
the previous one one that was done um
some of the ones that done previous were
done by uh consultant and I think it's
better to be done inhouse uh or an
in-house representative be involved in
it it it takes more than one person to
be involved in it uh and I think it's um
wise to have uh a contractors
representative with the team that's
doing it it it's useful from a health
and safety point of view but also from
the point of view of the contractor
getting first firsthand uh idea of what
what we have found and what needs to be
addressed thank you councel pH you want
to
come I think you would have done a few
of
these any further
comments would someone like to put the
uh that the report be received and the
council Implement all recommendations
and suggestions contained in the report
which is quite a big ask
May B Bell moves and councelor Phillips
II all those in favor please say
I against it's
carried do we need to do a
recommendation to the effect of what
council Stringer Rose or was that noted
by staff to send that motion
noted so that brings to the end the um
public side um we'll just have for we
break and then we'll go into exclusion
of public side
what